the one we've been waiting for reject
nation what's going on we are going to
watch some new rock stars their easter
eggs and break down
for the loki season one finale i bet the
first half of this
breakdown it's just eric boss going
thank god
thank god it was kang oh my god
i keep my job but also i wanted to say
thank you to
eric boss for shouting us out in that
deadpool and cork video he did the other
day even mentioned us in the pin comment
as well my reaction to someone else
reacting to a trailer what am i the real
reject
i meant a lot more more than you know
amigo
and uh yeah anywho loki great finale if
you haven't seen our reaction for it
it's now up on youtube now let's see
every single thing that we missed
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 6 the season finale for all time
always
which deprives us of jet ski mobius i
know
that major's wickedly talented
performances he who remains
a variant of the references look there's
so much deeper meaning hidden in all the
details of this episode so let's break
down this finale frame by frame to
celebrate me getting the theory right
for a change
also you can get our loki inspired merch
at new rockstarsmerch.com like our loki
out of time shirt and
our loki gator polo and a mobius on a
jet ski shirt but the window is closing
fast so you gotta jump off that's a
great shirt
absolutely a great shirt title we
actually hear the music of it's been a
long long time by harry james and helen
forrest which first played in captain
america the winter soldier and then more
memorably in the final scene of avengers
end game that was the moment steve
rogers created one of the many variant
branches that could have destabilized he
who remains sacred timeline
see i think that's great already just to
start off with the first
hint at like variant timelines have
introduced an end game the big question
about steve rogers 2 like wait a minute
you know how that was a big debate
we were first learning about all this is
like how we can see rogers get away with
that though how does he not create a
branch timeline
and it started off with uh the music
from that scene specifically oh
so so in the know they know what they're
doing over there then we hear other
iconic sounds from mcu past which at
first play over the character as they
appeared in the marvel title animation
but then build into a cacophony as the
timeline orbits around his citadel in a
flat circle
time unfolding all at once from his
perspective but because i'm insane i've
broken down
pretty much everything hidden in me
[Music]
[ __ ] congratulating ant-man during
civil war way to go
way to go hope vandy's lying to scott
lang and ant-man that's how you punch
yes that's how you punch
hulk roaring oh i'm already in love with
this
t'challa's
they found the exact one that black
panther said that chadwick boseman said
because that's a
that's a thing he says and they found
the exact take from the movie
no it's this scene specifically
impressive impressed spider-man's web
shooter
scott's first meeting with falcon and
ant-man you wouldn't have heard of me
no you wouldn't have heard of me natasha
talking to coulson in avengers
let me put you on hand let me put you on
hold peter quill and guardians of the
galaxy
dance off bro dance off bro
thor in ragnarok he's a friend from work
he's a friend from work
cap versus captain in-game i can do this
all day yeah i know i can do this all
day
yeah mjolnir i think reverting to cap
and end game
[Music]
wow younger ant-man i'll show you
and i'll show you ferocity carol danvers
and captain marvel
higher further faster baby higher
further faster baby that's right
loki two thanos and infinity war we have
we have a hulk porg the loki and
ragnarok
how long did this take to add planning
in guardians of the galaxy
i have part of a plan natasha
loki in avengers i got red in my life
just to decipher them all at once doctor
strange
[Music]
i've come to bargain vision to ultron
i was born yesterday talk to loki and
avengers
the word of that shield big guy in thor
you're big fought bigger
fury's speech and avengers
there was an idea stark knows this
hawkeye speech to one to an ultron or
only on detail
number two right now these final words
in infinity war
oh this is what this was all for this is
all building tours
the ultimate easter egg sequence
banners big line and avengers
that's my secret captain
i'm always angry ant-man in the wasp
[Music]
you sent my suit to the mail and it
sounds like the voice of carly
morgenthau in there
winter soldier
and kaiselius to dr strange
the time is the true enemy of us all
time kills everything
and then it ends with a subtle baby cry
baby dude it's actually hard to find but
it is the sound of baby loki crying
in that flashback giant ward
now the fact that you guys found the
baby cry
that's that is so nutty to me that is
loving attention to detail both on the
part of the sound designers who made it
and on the part of the new rock stars
who broke it down
because you know the lines are
intentional absolutely and then for them
to take the time to break this down
compliment it with here's the actual
clip and take that it's from so you know
we're right it's incredible because some
of those i was when there's a baby
crying i'm like
they could loop anyway baby can't think
of any baby crime maybe it means like
the beginning of time or something a new
life was just more specifically tuned
to baby loki that's crazy that was
amazing that should be a clip on youtube
yeah right here right yeah which this is
this is
now you'll notice there's a bit of a
loki bias among these since this history
is being filtered through the
perspective of a witness
observing loki's entire life start to
finish in particular
then we pull out from our solar system
now hearing a lecture from philosopher
alan watts about time
watts argued that time isn't really the
past causing the events of the future
but in truth just an imaginary concept
that we perceive from where we are in
the present
similar to the non-linear way he who
remains perceives time and then we zoom
out from the galaxy and we hear neil
armstrong's first words on the moon
meanwhile a mysterious ship soars past
us now this doesn't look like any of the
grains of the galaxy ships
nor one that nasa would use or one that
i think sword would use
especially this far out in the solar
system but i'm thinking it could be one
piloted by
kang enemies the fantastic how great
would that be if that
is that's your easter egg that is
fantastic for how great would that be
i think that would be awesome and then
it's a moment we can all point back to
and be like see nobody called it
yeah scepteric violence then we hear the
voice of climate activist greta
thundberg
as all of the galaxies our known
universe appears to be contained within
this blue sphere which then condenses
and then explodes maybe a depiction of a
big bang or a future big bang an event
that would have created the infinity
stones big bang
activism
and then the voice of nelson mandela we
have fought for the right
to experience speech as tchaikovsky's
music from swan lake
plays representing a battle between
light and dark like the apathetic yet so
benevolent variant
of kang versus the darker more menacing
variants who end up conquering
in the end we realize everything we have
just seen has been set inside of one
black hole
that neighbors another as the music
shifts like a radio dial to beethoven's
pure release
which he wrote as an ode to his lover
perhaps reflecting the way kang's
actions may have been
pure ravonna everything we're seeing
here is really an astronomical geography
of the spatial relationship between
these universes which he who remains
later describes as stacked on top of
each other and then we dive into
that second black hole a separate
reality now as we hear the voice of
classic loki from last episode
and then we briefly see one planet
colliding into another perhaps this was
lamentous one and then we stretch into a
bi frosty 2001 space odyssey stargate as
we hear
first liberian president ellen johnson
sir leaves 2006 speech motivated
by women jesse
motivated by women throughout the world
and then visions big line from one
division what is grief
if not love personally what is grief our
contribution to the history of great
quotes
persevering i remember the first time
hearing that life
that was from a poem with verses about
her history being rewritten which does
happen to sylvia and loki at the end of
this episode
and no one remembers them the final
things we hear during this montage are
sylvie's voice from last episode open
your eyes
open your eyes and then some morse code
this could be the 1962 morse message
that was beamed out to space
and we see the citadel at the end of
time with this cracked design which is
also reflected in he who remains time
twister on his wrist and his
tableau looks a lot like pottery
representing how he who remains likely
had to piece it together from broken
shards of that past multiversal war
to create this kind of neutral ground
and foreshadowing the way that this
timeline will
splinter and crack once more in the
episode's end blanking this entrance or
two giant hourglasses
and staying true to this series wizard
of oz parallels their slow walk down the
hall does mirror the nervous
walk to meet the wizard just reveal that
man behind the curtain is a far more
comedic figure than we expected we gotta
give credit
like a sincere congratulations to the
production design
on this show like what they have
mustered together the vfx team the
practical effects the set pieces of how
they visually are
consistent and reflective of the actual
storytelling it's so
well detailed and has deeper meaning
it's easy to just go it has good effects
yeah that stuff takes forever yeah yeah
really build a world and for a story in
the mcu that is so
far out and is introducing us to so many
different
new things like they're all like the tva
is distinct
this you know kronos castle at the end
of time is very distinct
all very colorful even you know and some
people have criticized that in the past
and it seems like they've really upped
their game yeah on all the production
designs
yes thank you for validating
but before we even get there miss minute
scares the [ __ ] out of us in this
chamber with looming hooded figures with
clocks for
faces kind of like a creepier form of
what miss minutes essentially is a
clock-faced greeter
and note how later she's late to meet
rince slayer therefore she cannot be in
two places at once
and she offers hey that's a great catch
both of y'all back into the timeline in
a way that won't disrupt things
similar to the offer made in the matrix
to the humans really this whole episode
is kind of playing out like the
architect scene and matrix reloaded yeah
that's
a lot more fun to watch minutes offers
loki his chance to rule
you can kill thanos
yeah natalie's violin theme returns the
music that played over loki watching his
own life back in episode one
but not to his own death but to the
deaths of friega and odin
[Music]
that is who he is really thinking about
in this moment a chance to see them in
thor
again now trailer footage showed some
shots of king loki on the
throne and back at the top of stark
tower presumably these were going to be
shown here as loki imagined these
possibilities
that trailer footage was throwing a
whole lot
if anything that was helped supporting a
wrench and that there might not be a
king
to show up in the show it was that
footage as the main supporting argument
that it could be another loki because we
haven't seen that shot yet
this is kind of crazy to see how much
that something's not in here
is one of the main supporting arguments
for what it's like no it's probably that
loki
yeah and now we're left to wonder are
they sitting there going
whoo that really threw people off before
they've seen they're going to the plan
i would like to see that scene i hope
they release it now back in the tva
rensselaer notices mobius ring stains on
the table
something that he did not remember
leaving which could connect to his total
memory reset at the end of this episode
make me wonder the tva could have been
reset before all this
many times now in the matrix that was
actually the sixth incarnation
a lot of matrix in this episode i
wouldn't put it past them to have reset
it multiple times considering the memory
wiping and it can't be the first time
that
it's like oh it's only sylvie who's the
first person to be able to crack into
the variant's real past i must have had
mishaps along the way
i took it as timeline was rewritten by
the end some people think it's just
completely alternate timeline that runs
parallel but i think it's a rewrite i
mean it could
easily be either but it sort of seemed
like yeah something is
so wrong that it's like parts of this
tva reality are the same and some of
them have changed it's like if it is the
same
tva as before just now different it
feels like the effects are like way more
immediate and tangible because you know
things are altering versus just like oh
you just gotta find the right door to
the right tv ravana gets a mystery file
he thinks this will be more useful who
yeah notice how here rensselaer does not
seem to know who he who remains
is but in the later scene she suddenly
seems more agitated and she gripes that
he's the only one with free will
so what did she learn from this file
well later mobius reveals that ren
slayer actually came from fdr
high school in fremont ohio in 2018
where she was apparently the principal
based on her having an office
and that ohio state diploma listing her
name as
rebecca tormunein an alias that
rensselaer actually uses in the comics
when she goes to the year 1903
so i love it she goes from a name
sounding like terminate to one sounding
like slayer now on her desk you'll see
more pens like the one that we saw and
around this school are posters of
fdr but also eleanor roosevelt in her
office and then a bunch more posters of
coat drives
and this being homecoming week and that
is interesting because homecoming is of
course normally in the autumn but autumn
2018
in the mcu would have been a few months
after the snap which occurred in the
spring of that year
so perhaps this coat drive is for
displaced kids and families during the
blip
and the reason she joined the tva could
have been blip related because ravana
branslayer is of course king's love
interest in the comics
so maybe here in the show he has
something over her like she could have
been destined to have been dusted and
that could have left behind a child who
died without her
so to keep her sacred timeline self
undusted and that kid
safe she continues to work for kang as
his objectified doll
i have to believe they had a reason but
here upon learning this truth she leaves
the last time
in search of free will which could be
her searching for a reality with a
different kang variant who might give
her a better deal which could lead to
the kang the conqueror who overtakes the
tva in the final scene
back in the citadel loki wait a minute
okay
need to get a little grasp on this
theory here uh
so the idea is that she knows her actual
past
and she's not freaked out at the thought
of being a variant
is that the starter of this theory
uh because she's saying that she's
motivated to work
within the tva still continue on because
she knows of her actual past on earth
and so like she wants to make sure that
that is maintained and that her
earth self doesn't get blipped and is
thus able to care for
these children let's just hear it again
[Music]
so the idea is that she agrees
to join the tva and then has her memory
wiped
then in that scene on the couch she's
learning the truth and remembering why
she joined the tva
yeah because possibly had a child left
behind like yeah because possibly later
getting dusted means that this kid would
have been left to
yeah to the because she didn't know at
all who kang is here
no or or yeah whoever the major time
yeah when miss minutes gives her the
file she's like
who is this from you know yes that's
what i think is okay
i don't know that's kind of that's a
major theory
for all of that to have happened in that
one scene and to explain why she seems
like kind of
rattled and stuff like that i guess i
could imagine that yeah although i don't
know i feel like it could just as easily
be like
her learning generally that what she
thought was
is not yeah it's a damn coat drive
poster that damn coach
yeah i know maybe she's just really good
what's that coach i posted for it must
be blip related oh my god i think i know
everything about her
reality needs to work out so that those
kids get their coats
you think it'd be easier for kids to get
coats during a time when fifty percent
of the population there's so many left
over there probably over here you leave
the codes thanos back in the citadel
loki and silvia reach the chamber with
the ceiling cogs and pendulums bells but
then on the floor a depiction of the
lunar cycle
all of these are various ways of keeping
time but also
time keeper statues three still standing
but a fourth one
shattered in the comics there was a
fourth time keeper named the oracle of
siwa who is exiled to ancient egypt for
informing the fantastic four of events
to come perhaps this statue was
shattered during the past multiversal
war between kangs
and he who remains couldn't put it back
together or this could be some evidence
of a past attempted uprising in one of
the past tva resets
where one of the times who remains to
help a variant get to him and then he
remains responded by
expelling that one faulty timekeeper and
destroying his statue that represented
him but then the man behind the curtain
we've been talking about is revealed
he will revenge she's still calling me
out
creepy right
i like it yes he who remains is actually
the name of the elderly tva caretaker at
the citadel at the end of time
who builds the timekeepers in the comics
and although he's never explicitly named
kang in this episode he who remains is
100 confirmed to be a variant of kang
the conqueror jonathan majors was cast
as kang for ant-man the was quantomania
he is dressed like immortus who is
another form of kang from the comics he
said that its variant was from the 31st
century when kang nathaniel richards was
born
he calls himself a conqueror and yeah
this pays off all the clues the show has
given us from renslayer to eliath to the
tower for kang enterprises the shell
company
rensselaer's id of a23 which was their
appearance together in the comics
avengers 23
and notice how here the light casts his
face in blue
like his comic book book now i know he
eats an apple which could mean a lot of
things
it's a symbol of newtonian knowledge you
know point and later on in his office is
this chalk board with equations that use
integrals and if i remember from
calculus a b
in high school this is calculus and
jurassic newton is credited as a
co-creator of calculus but the apple
also recalls doctor strange's use of an
apple to first demonstrate time
manipulation in the mcu but also reminds
us of that episode two word problem for
miss minutes that asked about the last
mcu big bad
thanos using him eating apples as an
example of course apples are also
associated with the forbidden fruit of
the guardians
from used to tempt adam and eve by the
serpent
and in this episode he who remains
offers these adam and eve figures
chances to beat gods
and reverses himself a few times this
episode as the devil damn it i want to
know exactly what the apple means
marvel answers to some questions can we
get like a scientific breakdown of
apples
nothing should be left to interpretation
any longer marvel
there's no such thing as subtext it's
all text but i can just imagine
eric just going what's the apple mean
can we get 100 apples now to pull off
this effect if he remains dodging
silvia's blows
hiddleston and demartino must have had
to shoot their action on a green screen
and then had to be layered into that
elevator with majors but this render was
left
just rough enough around the edges that
leaves the characters and
us feeling emotionally detached from
this seemingly
untouchable immortal he who remains
reveals this is all scripted and we see
if you look closely at his book that
sylvia is id as variant l1190
and notice how he lifts that book i like
how he does a subtle little adjustment
of his time twister to draw attention to
it since this
is the key to controlling the room and i
think he ultimately wants sylvia to take
it and kill him so that he can respawn
in a more dangerous
form like i think the council of kangs
know that loki and silvi's union
make them true nexus beings that
threaten their empire
and so he who remains really feigns this
candidness with this phony offer to
replace him
while really he is driving a wedge
between them the whole time
it's all a manipulation
interesting that your head
would go to that
selfie you think you can trust this guy
he who remains later says without the
tva everything burns jonathan majors is
having a blast hamming up the
eccentricities in this jaded sing-songy
tone
he's constantly moving to new
physicalities just to punctuate and live
in this monologue kind of like a guy on
the last day of his job
super dangerous super fun to watch you
could actually compare him to heath
ledger's joker who also says similar
words
everything burns and when he's seated at
his desk he's framed with his head in
the middle of his spiral window in the
background
kind of like the whole universe orbiting
around
personally i love that i'm in love with
jonathan major's performance in this
episode
i think we both are right i've seen that
there's some people who
really were not for it which i can
understand and some people kind of just
middle of the road about it you know
maybe not super glowing i personally
think that
his performance was captivating and i
really loved the way they shot it
because it could have been very easy to
make that really boring and really dull
but you need an exciting performer in a
moment like that okay could have just
been the architect
versus like two talking heads with a
bunch of information
yeah well it's a testament to both his
performance and i think too also the
direction because it's a bunch of
very deliberate choices and yeah how to
track in and and track back
out and how to emphasize what he's doing
in ways that are
using you know the magic of camera
motion but in the subtlest ways possible
to really enhance just the gravitas of
his position
because it's such an expositional heavy
scene but you can't lose the emotional
weight of what's going on and they
managed to keep all that in a
moment of tension and intrigue yet this
lively performance helps keep it a
little bit
uh exciting yeah yeah absolutely so i
thought it was very purposeful how
everything was i don't think they were
like we don't we can't tell jonathan
majors what not to do
it's like it's very intentional i mean
this is the guy at the end of time who's
like pulling all the straight like you
kind of want to give him
center stage with your visual language
and he explains a variant of himself in
the 31st century discovered parallel
universes the same time as other
variants
for a while there was peace narcissistic
self congratulatory peace i love you
shoes i love your hair oh man nice nose
thanks man yeah majors might be joking
about his own
recognizable nose but really he knows he
is sexy
we see how the kang variants invented
time doors reset charges the computers
pruning sticks the tva used but they
ended up
in this multiversal war meaning that
miss minute's animation was actually
telling the truth about that
just that it wasn't the time keepers who
ended it but he who remains apparently
repelling these even worse evil kings
[Music]
the figurines shapeshift into prayerful
and grateful poses
he says i've lived a million lifetimes
i've gone through every every scenario
this is
the only way similar to how dr strange
said that he saw 14 million 605 future
outcomes but that only one was a
successful way forward yeah
there was no other way now of course he
remains his offer is very much like a
willy wonka style offer to them to take
over his job but i love how majors nods
at that with his pose here
or you're a liar
or malaya yeah leaning on his face and
as he says he is older than he looks and
this game is for the young and hungry
the camera pulls back from him
making him look smaller and smaller and
more diminished in the window spiral
as if his influence is appearing to fade
then he snaps at sylvie grow up
grow up sylvie murderer hypocrite
similar to how kai silly's called out
the ancient one hypocrite
because among sorcerers no one really
has the moral high ground but then
everything shifts in this scene but now
we
you have a chance to do them for a good
reason
we just crossed the threshold
yeah that thunder was the sound of the
sacred timeline breaking
up and fitting to use thunder for that
because as it branches it does look a
lot like heat lightning evoking the
moment the ancient one slowed down time
in the moment of her death a similar
moment where she just like he who
remains here could not foresee beyond
that point so what caused this
ravona's pact with another kang or could
he who remains justifying free will
subversion had been the thing that
sylvie decided she was just going to
kill him no matter what loki told her
either way
that break makes it so that when loki
returns to the tva it has
already warped and reset so that a
different case
okay that makes more sense to me because
i was actually talking with
warren uh yesterday but wait a minute
he's in a rewritten timeline but didn't
sylvia push him through the door
the ten pad door before sylvie killed
him
yeah that's what i thought it was all
coming from that choice right there but
it was already
happening yeah before and uh yeah it's
really interesting yeah absolutely
that's just a question i was
like one of the one of the like there's
a lot of questions but that was one of
the main questions that i was asking
myself last night he remains removes his
time twister and slides it over but
notice how his gesture
again sliding his hand across the table
and the framing makes it look like
it is still on his hand which could be a
clue that this offer is really a baiting
switch because
both alternatives lead to his victory
loki and sylvie duel upon their early
clash he remains jumps in his seat in
the corner in excitement which is
similar to how palpatine loved watching
luke and vader fight and before that
anakin and dooku fight because either
way the mastermind is already won
it's so tragic to see these two fights
largely in the way it parallels what
loki told sylvie as an answer to what
love
is back in episode 3. love is a dagger
it's a weapon to be wielded far away
or up close you can see yourself in it
it's beautiful
until it makes you bleed but ultimately
when you reach for it
it isn't real yeah loki wields his love
for still up close
she makes him bleed and when he reaches
for it it isn't real instead classic
loki's wisdom really reigns supreme
the blades are worthless in the face of
a loki's sorcery
but despite all this loki does make a
key concession oh
i know i don't want to hurt you i don't
want a throne
i just want you to be okay signaling
that he
learned the core lesson that sylvie laid
out for him earlier this season
this isn't about you oh wait i love
that yeah i never picked i did not pick
up on that at all so as much as people
are like this episode's mainly
a setup for the future of marvel and
season two and i didn't really have much
complain about it just because of the
fact that it
we are getting a season two and i felt
like loki's arc was actually completed
in episode five so it didn't matter to
me as much that episode six was doing
set up when we were gonna get a season
two so you gotta keep your audience
hooked and i thought was great anyway
that line there of just
he's like truly looking out for someone
else in that moment someone he really
cares about that he's not being selfish
and narcissistic so that development
actually is complete
in that scene right there i actually did
pick up i i i was like no i pretty much
aren't
by five yeah that's the final challenge
yeah to prove
that the growth has really taken he's
tempted yeah exactly yes like here is
the ultimate answer here i could put you
right down on him
that's a good point always wanted but
still yeah [ __ ] can't believe that flew
over my head
no but it's great yeah and it's not like
i love
like all kinds of easter eggs were fun
but it's especially those contextual
ones
that make the episode that much better
yeah yeah deaf kudos to you guys
i love the episode that much more now
mainly because of that
but as he tumbles back through the time
door into the tva theater the window
lights on the floor go in opposing
directions which is odd because
presumably they're coming from the same
exterior light source the way these
lights paralleled loki and mobius's
opposition episode 4 they now mirror the
opposition between loki
and silvi but on a more literal level it
also shows how this new tva that loki
has found himself in
does not revolve according to the same
gravity as the old one did so sylvie
stabs he who remains and he
winks and says yeah back in episode 4
after sylvie beheaded the timekeeper
android and the other two shut down if
you listen closely
you could hear a voice whisper see you
soon
[Music]
i forgot all about that yeah i remember
that being pointed out
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i've completely
forgot about it but not having a context
for it yeah
oh it's such a great foreshadowing of
what's to come timekeepers eliminated
see you soon his final line see you soon
circle that i love it the sacred
timeline splits into branches of
branches of branches and the
chronomonitor screen confirms that many
of these branches
overlap with each other and looking back
at the cosmic version of it some regions
grow a
bright red which could be the incursion
that we saw in one division's
post-credits scene and been the cause of
wanda suddenly hearing her children
calling to her from another reality
so yes we are looking at the multiverse
of madness that doctor strange two will
take place in where the scarlet witch
will be the rising threat he has to face
perhaps even the logical basis for how
alfred molina doc och and jamie fox
electro will appear in spider-man no way
home hopefully we get a trailer for that
very soon meanwhile loki finds the tva
changed as he passes a bunch of hunters
who don't really care about him it's
hard to tell but one of these must be
hunter k5e
listed in the credits as eugene cordero
meaning casey must have either got
promoted or
[Music]
pruning fish left and right wow even
casey got a payoff somewhere
the end credits give out whoa what
amazing detective work there
i hope he comes back it's so impressive
to me that you [ __ ] it
always pay attention to hey man marvel's
doing wonders for
credits watching because you can even
find relevant info now there
and people said there was nothing really
that mattered after the episode ended
sh some people said it a decent amount
of people
and then in the archives he finds mobius
and b15 who have no idea who he is
which is really odd because even before
he was a detained variant loki was the
freaking god of mischief with an
infamous reputation so this must have
been a hard memory wipe reset the
timekeeper statues have been replaced
with
he who remains variant in this case it
is kang the conqueror which we know
because he's wearing his conqueror
wardrobe this might remind you of that
final twist in tim burton's 2001
planet of the apes with the lincoln
memorial but just by looking at this
while the tva may change on a dime its
true creator is now
thanks to sylvie for all time always and
the credits confirm that loki will
return for a second season and with
kang's confirmed appearance in ant-man
the watts quantomania in february 2023
i'm thinking season two could come at
the end of 2022 or maybe in the first
weeks of 2023 to lead into that film
ant-man and the wasp left a quantum
realm
city in the background that i've been
theorizing could be kang's kingdom of
chronopolis and kang and quantomania
could live beyond that film to be the
villain of a future fantastic food
for an avengers secret wars conflict but
whenever we see kang next with an actor
as talented and versatile as jonathan
majors it would not surprise
me if he brings a whole new
characterization to his conqueror
variant we still have much to learn
about him and that is what makes him so
dangerous
and so delightful i think it's so
amazing how
after end game you kind of feel like
what okay what if when it comes to like
villain and threat maybe things peaked a
little bit
but maybe i mean i didn't really doubt
it like now they got creative ways to go
i like what they're opening up but that
question does arise
well now it's gonna keep arising but
with kang the conqueror they're doing
something so different with him
it's not just a bunch of teases of king
the conqueror to come to before you see
jonathan majors doing anything in the
marvel cinematic universe like you're
introducing him
early on as his very end you're really
letting this the future storytelling be
affected by
king the conqueror versus the first
three phases were of like we're building
to
beating thanos you know eventually
having a big
fight with them yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and adhere it's like king's
presence is truly going to be felt
throughout going forward you know oh
yeah whereas
you instead of just waiting for a
post-credits scene to get some nuggets
or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah one i mean too like
the possibilities of
other kang variants means a lot of cool
stuff for the potential for
the performances for the story context
for the use of the character all that
stuff
i want to thank you all so much for
joining me on these breakdowns of loki
this show is a true master class in
world building and storytelling and i
hope the details and connections i've
been able to find have enriched the
viewing experience for you
i'll be back with plenty more marvel
theories and future breakdowns so be
sure to subscribe to new rockstars
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars thank you
again for watching bye
oh he looks so happy he got a win that
many wins and you've won our hearts
missed your boss
awesome boss top boss boss
and if he was working at the tva we call
you cleric eric
claire adds good rhymes right rhyme
yeah yeah it's a great rhyme i'm out
you're out of uh okay um uh
um how about this video is over now
that's
because that's the
yeah all right guys thank you so much
for joining us on this journey and i
really know that i really appreciate
everyone who
like actually waits for our reaction to
do rock stars we read our
low-key reactions we'll see comments
about like what are wearing boss is
going to say no and i love that it's
kind of funny to be
like this the reactors too you are the
official
growth off of the side of theirs
guys thank you so much last but not
least let's do it
jean-fred the jeter as i was thinking of
who could we possibly
shout out in this episode uh yeah anyway
gene so uh i was thinking in this
episode
about who i could relate to the show to
kang the conqueror and then i started
thinking
man jonathan majors he's got such a
great monologue a lot of great
expression
reminding me of the voice messages you
send me on instagram
each one of them feels like an odyssey
through space and time
you're like an attorney you're supposed
to you're saying all sorts of creative
stuff and i'm like what kind of
thousands it's like so
sophisticated and out there and
theoretical and artistic
i just could never hold a camera to you
buddy so send me some more voice memos
love you and uh we'll catch you on the
next one yeah thank you thank you gene